so like you you talked about your
opinion of like the modern anime scene
so like
what are some of your favorite anime
because we i don't think we
mentioned that it's normie as hell but i
mean i always just enjoyed evangelion
like back then because i mean i'd say
it's less normally now than it is
i guess so but back then so in australia
uh yeah i'd seen a lot of stuff but then
it came out on tv on um sbs
which is like a public channel in
australia it's like where they like air
a lot of the international shows right
right yeah it's my you know their show
like there was um there was a guy called
des mangan who presented like you know
the
the the cult movies and stuff and
sometimes it'd be anime and i was like
animated tonight yeah yeah back then
whatever you could whatever you could
get you took it like
it'd be professionally subtitled be
really good and they would
show evangelion uh they had like an
anime block where they showed some stuff
for a while
and that was good because that came out
on tv so everyone had a shared
experience of it at that time
so you know what i mean like it that i
think it's very it's very important that
shared experience
when it comes to this sort of media i
think like it's mostly
about video games that sort of thing
like you know if you meet someone who's
played like whatever final fantasy 7
it's like
you immediately have a huge thing in
common right yeah like what's your
favorite part
yeah yeah they've all done the same
thing at the same time yeah and that was
probably the first time that like
mainstream anime was shown on tv
so you sort of discovered other people
who are into it too because they'd watch
it it was accessible
yeah so i guess that it had a bit of an
impact and it was very um
you know it was it wasn't the standard
monster of the week's show there's a lot
more to it and i'm not trying to sound
like it's super deep or anything because
it wasn't but
it was just um really it solidified like
it was
engaging right it was very engaging it
wasn't afraid to
to you know make something different
like a show that's a bit different
but at the same time used every trope
yeah you know combined like you have
what whatever
that's the weird thing about a lot of
anime it is the most tropey unique
shows that for some reason get the most
attention it's like
you look at it like someone will look at
him being like like ava for instance
right
someone will look at ava and being like
whoa i've never seen anything like this
at all
but at the same time it's the type of
show where another person will look at
it be like
this has every trope that i've ever seen
dude uh
one punch man yeah okay i i
my wait my cousin my cousin's kids
a few a couple of christmases ago when i
went back and they were talk they
started talking about oh yeah we watch
this thing one punch man it's really
cool
and i blew their minds by going
this is actually based on a little kids
tv show called anpanman
and this that character is based on like
the dragon ball character this one and
this it was actually voiced by the same
guy
you dropped the anime knowledge on there
i just i explained something worldwide
[ __ ] you [ __ ] scoot them man okay so
everything you like is actually based on
something else
your life is a lie don't be happy i'm
going to tell you why that's exactly i
was i was aiming to destroy them because
it was just destroying those destroying
them with facts and history see that's
what this is and and so you actually
like this you should actually like
but again it's a gateway thing like if
hey anything gets people into it it's
like
look i don't you who cares anymore like
oh you're a bunch of
normie fans what do you know it's like
no it you start somewhere
you go this far it's like the same thing
like you guys have done drifting
if you don't want to go any further it's
like well why would you like
if you don't understand enough that's
fine you enjoyed it it was like you got
you got your adrenaline hit and it was
some weird stuff you've never done
before
you have a new experience that you've
done it's in japan like
you've done drifting in japan yeah like
that was um
i guess this is the thing that i have to
offer to other people and i always try
and
not force it on them but if i can at
some opportunity like for example um
when uh reckful and sodapoppin came to
japan
for their legendary stream on twitch uh
their irl stream
right i hunted them down and said you
have to come
and go drifting because team orange had
those
two of their drift cars at a diver which
is only about
very close and yeah less than an hour
from anywhere in tokyo
to uh to go drifting so because i know
them i hooked it up i said yeah come
here we'll meet here we'll take them
send them drifting they went out that
night and did um
rem and ram cosplay on the streets so i
guess they had a good day you know yeah
yeah yeah
other guys like um the irl streamer jake
and bake the japanese
streamer i i got him a ride in
um a d1 grand prix car was about maybe
1200 horsepower
gtr uh you know live streaming it to
like whatever it was like twenty
thousand twelve thousand whatever people
yeah i love to if if i can just present
it to people
as like a because i honestly i think it
is a really good
part of japanese culture that is not
only fun
and relatable but you know i mean any
like you said like you know it because
of
fast it's not fast fast and furious
people have seen initial d
yeah and i think it's a it's a cool
thing that i like people to experience
and i
i think welcoming as well yeah yeah yeah
they were really friendly to us at their
finally every community was like
because i was gonna say i mean like you
talked about how to you know getting
people to experience this for the first
time i mean we've
i'm sure we've done that like
introducing our friends and everything
into anime
where we can just like recommend the
show or something but i feel like it's
infinitely harder with drifting because
like the as we've talked about the
barrier of entry is like
so high and i feel like it's it's one of
those hobbies where
no one just no one just casually drifts
you know
you can't just be a casual drifter you
like you're like either
in this all the way or like it's
something you experienced
once and you know i would love to go
drifting more
um it was a [ __ ] hell of an
experience but at the same time it's
like do i have the time and the money to
commit to this
and it's it's you know it's it's
something about catcher
he said he spent like what like 30k was
it
that's a minimum that's probably god's
like monthly allowance from catcher come
on
quick he was telling me on the train
here that he's like man
i i would go drifting i just have to
quit gadget
[Laughter]
but it's so hard i i think one thing
that i really appreciate about your
channel in particular and
to anyone listening uh that whereas a
lot of
youtubers here who live in japan who are
foreign it feels like an outsider
looking in on a lot of the content and
what was really refreshing i think from
your videos what i
i got was that it was like you were in
it with them and that you knew all the
like all the big players in this yeah it
was really cool seeing that aspect
because i thought when i
first watched your videos it was going
to be like hey i'm here let's find out
what's going on i'm going to see what's
happening but you like saying hi to
everyone everyone knew you
it was so cool yeah it was really cool
seeing that like
you get a youtuber in japan who is
really deep in this scene to the point
of where you know i'm even the people in
the japanese scene would know you
yeah it's really cool seeing that that
mostly came from the fact that back in
the day when i was doing
uh journalist work you've been around so
long well it's it's like
if if i want to get access to cool stuff
i have to
make friends make friends i have to get
known to people i have to show them
you know i i would be serious any event
i would show up this is the thing about
this is the thing about
anything about japan especially is show
up obviously right now you can't really
do that
but if you want to be in something show
up talk to people
get to know people i mean i've been on
i've been on tours of um
like a couple of anime studios because
i'm friends with someone else who knows
someone else and you just
you know you because you know someone
and oh alexis you know that stuff why
don't we go you want to come too we're
doing something and
it's just knowing people and yeah
eventually guess it gets to a tipping
point where it's like you show up
oh yes alexia and that's what my friends
told me like when i first got here it's
like um
it's very difficult for a japanese
person to get to know and trust a
foreigner because they just assume that
you're not going to be here you know
yeah yeah or so and like another person
told me too like lexi you have to keep
going to track days again
like all the time because if you don't
they're just people are just going to
forget about you
straight away so i do make an effort to
even if i don't
even driving like oh i got today off
i'll go to the track
maybe i'll make i'll take my equipment
with me maybe if there's something cool
and make a video but otherwise i'll just
hang around and talk to people
and you know walk through the pits and
everyone morning
and then eventually they'll come to you
oh actually and they'll they'll have
something cool like and someone will be
like
oh are you driving today oh no i'm just
i just turned up it's like oh you want
to take my car out for a couple of laps
like hell yeah
i got my helmet in the van i'll bring my
helmet with me just in case
maybe go take a shirt off like a whole
yeah it's just show up and and do it and
it gets like that after a while i mean
i've been here 12 years so
and i've been coming here for longer
than that too so yeah i think that
kind of applies with any social security
absolutely right it's like it's just
you know it's about commitment right
like you just gotta if you want to be
known in that circle or you want to be
part of that circle whatever that circle
might be or whatever that niche might be
like
if you don't make an effort to want to
actually show
you know your commitment to it or want
to be like part of it then
you're not going to get in right yeah so
i mean like i was going to say like it's
the same thing with like you know with
like the anime industry as well like
once you know a couple of people
it's such a small industry that your
face just gets known everywhere as long
as you're staying committed to it like
that's really the only reason why like
any of us have like just like our friend
nabi
in like a nutshell right exactly he just
seems to know everyone and
when i ask him it's just he just says oh
you know i just know a guy who knows a
guy
i've just been around enough yeah i just
make my make you know go around and just
make myself
known yeah like that's so but the thing
is that's like so much easier said than
done
yeah you know because it is a lot of
commitment and it does take time and you
know it's not
guaranteed either that you're going to
get rid of no it's it's just you got you
just got to
build up recognition and everything
because i i uh
it was interesting you mentioned the
point that people in japan just assume
people
are going to be living here like
unpermanently
like it like because having lived abroad
in like few different countries
you know there's like you make some
expat friends sometimes
right who you are you could be like the
closest friends with them
for like a few years but then eventually
they're gonna move back
and it's really hard building like
building up a friendship from zero again
when you know sometimes that people
aren't gonna be here in like two or
three years
yeah i've definitely noticed that that i
even i made some friends when i just
moved here and i'm like oh cool i'm
making friends and then they left
yeah i was like damn finally started
getting a good list of friends going and
they all just [ __ ] left
yeah can you imagine they had their own
problems
how dare they
the audacity to have nationalities apart
aside from the place i'm living
right this moment